no story can truly begin without amazing
characters and sometimes when a
character is introduced for the first
time it's one of their most awesome
moments with the latter in mind we've
made a list of the top 20 character
debuts in anime ranging from Gabi maru's
first appearance to mahara Wrecking an
entire city with so many debuts to
choose from we've narrowed the list down
to the following characters so let's get
started part starting off this list we
have goo from one punch man now G is a
notable villain in the series as we all
know by now who has the makings of a
spectacular hero mangar readers know
even more about what to expect but
overall he's a character who has a
significant impact on one punch man's
world goo is the disciple of bang an
S-Class hero but his introduction was
less than heroic goo clearly declares to
everyone that he's on the side of the
monsters and proceeds to beat up a whole
bunch of criminals and Stitch his guards
he leaves Stitch himself into attacked
since he wants him to spread the word
about the monster goo G's character
design and general Vibe are pretty
intimidating and wild which adds to his
formidable strength too his voice is
great just makes his debut even
better up next we have ur's reveal from
Gintama it's always a kicker when a mass
character is revealed especially when
that character is exceptionally strong
and a villain during his debut utsuro
beats up nobou Soo and kagura and it's
not until gintoki arrives that he's
pushed back a bit the fight itself is
pretty epic but the best part is when
gintoki destroys utsuro mask only to see
his old teacher's appearance underneath
this leads to him breaking down in the
middle of the fight due to his memories
but the others help him out and finally
push back uro the character leaves a
lasting effect on gintoki adding to the
weight of the character's appearance the
guy also has an extremely strong healing
ability which is something the trio
would have to deal with properly down
the line an awesome villain with a calm
and cool character design just adds to
utsuro overall greatness and his role in
the series is hyped up during this
introduction to which does make me
wonder who else in Gintama debuted as
great as
[Music]
him next on the list we have another
villain debut which is goto from
parasite
how should you introduce the main
antagonist of a series well other animes
can definitely take pointers from goto's
introduction he's later revealed to be
one of the strongest parasites in the
story that much could be judged by the
first time he appeared in the anime when
he shows up he proceeds to kill more
than 20 members of the Yakuza in one of
the most brutal ways possible his
character design at the time looks very
simple with him just being a big buff
guy in a tank top but the way he
destroyed an entire game gang showed us
how much of a threat he really is later
on when migi senses multiple parasites
but only sees goto in their location it
leaves a sense of dread as goto's power
is harnessed through multiple parasites
setting him up as the main antagonist of
the series we see a much scarier version
of Goo later in the anime but his debut
was nothing to scarf at either so it
makes the later appearance much more
organic coming in at number six 17 we
have Diablo from the time I got
reincarnated as a
slime a primordial demon sounds like a
big deal especially when there are only
seven in the world so how is he
introduced in one of the funniest ways
possible what's the best way to fight
evildoers summon even more evil
creatures that's what rimu did when he
performed demon summoning after killing
around 20,000 farmer soldiers rimu
became became really vulnerable and
performed a greater demon summoning by
offering up all the bodies this is when
Diablo was summoned along with two other
demons in one of the most Sinister
rituals we've ever seen in the series
what he does next is to just show us how
strong a primordial demon is and that
even ryzen a wizard from a major Kingdom
has no chance against him Diablo looks
as cool as he as powerful and his casual
attitude while facing opponents just
makes him one of the best characters so
far I mean we all love demons and this
man doesn't
[Music]
disappoint
in a bizarre twist we have the pillar
men from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure the
pillar men are an ancient race of
humanoids with amazing strength
intelligence and nearly Immortal bodies
the first time we see them is when
they're sleeping inside a stone wall in
wacky poses that JoJo as a series is
known for the people who go up to them
at the time are men whose affiliations I
can't say without the video being
demonetized so it makes the villain's
introduction a little bit more shocking
once awoken wamo proceeds to casually
destroy the entire Squadron by sucking
the life out of them showcasing his
strength and intelligence before
Awakening the other two pillman the
villains already had some pretty solid
law going for them and the way these
three debut just makes their entire
introduction better the trio also have
pretty cool designs and their poses are
well just Jojo I suppose from the first
time I saw them I already thought Joseph
was going to have a hard time fighting
them demons in Demon slay are extremely
powerful and always pose a threat to Our
Heroes but the upper Moon rank one is
the strongest amongst these Tak only to
muan himself Goku shibo is introduced
during the meeting of the demons and he
goes to put araza in his place due to
his insubordination in his introduction
Goku shibo makes no physical actions but
his words are enough to strike fear even
into akaza who's shown to be an
exceptional fighter and made one of our
favorite hashiras into a donut the
second thing that catches everyone off
guard is how similar kokushibo looks to
the pillars of the demon corpse he has a
katana and the god to match you think he
was a Demon Slayer if not for the
obvious six ey staring at you now at
this point viers were struck with awe as
this particular demon didn't look like
something you could defeat and there
were a lot of questions that came about
after seeing a demon who used to be a
Demon Slayer well let's move on a bit
from Pure villains and go towards one of
Humanity's greatest weapons coming up
next on the list which is arima from
Tokyo
go arima's debut is impactful and
establishes him as a significant
character introduced as a skilled member
of the ghoul investigation team arima's
reputation precedes him for his
exceptional combat prowess and his calm
and collected demeanor his first
appearance during an operation showcases
how extremely strong he is since he
takes on the oneeyed owl one of the
biggest threats in the entire series
being a trip S rank ghoul he takes on
the Beast like it's not even a big deal
this introduction sets the stage for
arima's role in the series as a monster
investigator surrounded by an aura of
mystery and moving forward a lot of
other things come to light about this
strong yet mysterious character but
you're going to have to watch to find
[Music]
out at number 13 we have Gabby Maru from
hell's Paradise protagonist
introductions are normally pretty slow
as authors normally want to show the
viewers how the protagonist grows in a
series this isn't the case with Gabby
Maru his entire introduction is is how
hard he is to execute this man just
won't die his captures tried to cut off
his head but the blade breaks burning
him has Zero Effect getting pulled by
balls causes the balls to collapse with
exhaustion being dipped in boiling oil
doesn't even make him Flinch literally
every execution method fails and Gabby
Maru simply brushes it off while
seemingly showing everyone that he
doesn't want to die without fighting a
single person Gabby maru's overall
strength is shown and that just makes
the latter Parts where he actually does
fight all the more better he also looks
quite lanky and has a short thin body
type which isn't your typical MC style
it isn't until Sagi tries to execute him
that we see gabim Maru put up a fight
but the initial introduction set him up
for even better displays of raw power
and
[Music]
intelligence with that last entry done
we'll be moving back to villain
introductions with the next entry being
all for one from my hero
Academia
all for one burst onto the scene in my
hero Academia and it was totally worth
the wait he quickly became one of the
scariest bad guys in the whole show and
frankly that's because he is he seems
super chill but also crazy powerful
especially when he went head-to-head
with all might matching and sometimes
even beating his strength when he first
showed up he nearly wiped out all the
pro Heroes at the nomu factory and
seriously hurt best genius to the point
where we thought he may not survive and
all that in just a few attacks he also
delivers a Savage line by saying that he
doesn't even need best genius Quirk then
when facing off against all might he was
confident and unafraid of literally the
strongest hero in the world it was a
glorious introduction to an extremely
overpowered villain with an even more
overpowered
[Music]
quirk
the next antagonist we have on this list
is UA from bleach bleach has had its
fair share of a whole lot of character
debuts but none surpasses the
introduction of the strongest villain
known to the bleach Universe UA is
introduced in quite an ominous way
sitting on a throne with his
subordinates in front of him two of them
are having an argument but uar doesn't
like conflict in his presence so he do
what any San king would do he cuts off
one of their
arms also he does this without lifting a
finger which makes him all the more
badass his presence is like that of a
king and his power exceeds all
expectations since just his spiritual
pressure is enough to chop off a limb
his appearance marked the start of the
final Saga of bleach and showed us a
glimpse of the chaos that was about to
come now if you're enjoying the
character debut so far do like and
subscribe to the channel for for more
awesome content with that let's take a
look at the top
10 moving on to the top 10 of this list
we have Luol Lang from sword of the
stranger his debut was right at the
start of the movie where Luol Lang faces
off against a whole bunch of Bandits the
setting's awesome as luang and his
people are on a cliff while it's raining
when the bandits attack in full force
duang then proceeds to use a dead guide
as a shield from the reain of arrows to
get to the bandits before cutting them
down one after the other after killing
off these guys in an incredible display
of swordsmanship luang faces off against
the chief of the bandits barehanded he
blocks his attacks and takes his sword
before throwing it into his forehead
it's just so brutal and stunning the
animation makes it even better and just
looking at his power you already know
how strong luang would be if he goes all
out did I mention how even the
protagonist isn't shown until now it
just makes his impact even larger
[Music]
moving on we have one of the coolest
fights in recent times maha's debut in
the real world of jiujitsu Kaizen mahara
is the strongest Shiki gami that
wielders of the 10 Shadows technique can
summon the only problem is that no one's
been able to control mahara till now
since no wielder of the technique could
defeat him mahara can adapt to anything
and everything making it a being that
would simply get stronger and stronger
while fighting an opponent no his debut
is just amazing megum summons mahara
when he's in a really tight spot knowing
he'll be killed in the process as soon
as mahara is summoned it takes one blow
to knock out megumi before sukuna
appears to face off against it the fight
that took place between the two was just
absolutely stunning their fight was so
ground and chaotic that block of off the
block within Shibuya was being
disintegrated he just has to watch it to
know how it
[Applause]
[Music]
feels
next on the list we have Future Trunks
zipping into the present in Dragon Ball
Z Now fans of the series already know
how strong Frieza is considering it took
Goku everything he had to defeat the
monster Frieza was showcased to be
Goku's strongest adversary up to this
point and he was the reason Goku finally
unlocked his Super Saiyan transformation
so he could finally beat the guy seeing
that Frieza came back was something that
was horrifying for the fans as it meant
another brutal battle would take place
unfortunately for Frieza though trunks
showed up from the future after taking
out frieza's foot soldiers he proceeds
to power up into a Super Saiyan making
Frieza lose his mind trunks then
proceeds to wave off frieza's attacks
before cutting him into ribbons and
punching a hole through King cold trunks
defeating Frieza this casually showed
off his power as being possibly higher
than even Goku at the
time and his debut hit a sweet spot for
fans all
around
coming in at number seven we have maruem
from Hunter Hunter this character debut
is one of the most interesting ones
since it's basically a character being
born quite literally this is when the
king of the Chima ants meruem was
conceived in the world the debut was as
gruesome as the first time we saw a face
Huger rip out from a human being if
you're not aware this is a reference
from the aliens movie maruem ripped
through his mother leaving her for dead
before killing off a few other
subordinates as well he then proceeds to
kill and feed off a few humans too marm
is shown to be on a whole other level
when compared to everyone else we've
seen so far even Nero was determined to
be less powerful than the king of the
ants it's not until the end of the ark
that we see the peak of meruem's power
but there's no questioning that meruem's
debut marked a significant change in
Hunter
[Music]
Hunter next up we have zod's appearance
in
berserk until this point the anime
didn't showcase Supernatural entities in
full force it mostly consisted of
abnormally strong humans against other
humans using tactics and strategy but
this marked the turning point in the
anime as our protagonists realized that
the world wasn't as simple as they
thought it was sord was initially shown
in his human form which is intimidating
enough considering he even wielded a
blade that was much bigger than guts
while he stood near the bodies of
numerous soldiers when guts tried to
face him he was instantly pushed back
during the fight Zod also showed that he
was vastly experienced in fights and
didn't just rely on brute strength it's
not until guts lands a blow that Zod
transforms into his true monstrous form
now if you thought his humanoid
appearance was intimidating then you're
in for a surprise when you see just how
much more terrifying he can be good
thing Griffith showed up to save guts's
neck
lasting his way on this list we have
Kenny from Attack on Titan
[Music]
yeah we all know how strong the aans are
since we've seen both Mikasa and Levi in
action Levi is quite effectively the
strongest person on Humanity side and
it's a good thing too since otherwise
the Titans would be at a significant
Advantage so what happens when an aaman
faces an aaman that's what Kenny's debut
was all about Kenny aaman debuted in one
of the most iconic ways possible he
directly attacked Levi with his Squad
and made Levi go on the defensive he
proved himself by putting the strongest
member of Humanity on the run and he had
all the powers and prowess the aans
possessed the sequence was gorgeously
animated too and just made everything
even better Kenny would prove to be a
major threat but as far as debuts go
this deserves to be in the top five on
any
[Music]
list before we reveal the top three list
we have kaido's debut in one
[Music]
piece
kaid now this is the time when we first
see kaido trying to take his own life
before that it's worth mentioning that
kaido is known as an emperor of the sea
one of the four strongest Pirates around
and his nickname is the strongest
creature in the world the first time
kaido appears is 10,000 m above the sea
on a sky island then he jumps right off
while the narrator explains how kaido is
practically unkillable as all execution
methods on him have failed much like a
certain gabim Maru the hollow kaido
proceeds to land on an island becoming a
mini meteor and creating a kaido shaped
crater in the ground he came out of that
alive with barely a headache kaido's
debut showed how durable he is and his
form was absolutely massive his body was
extremely muscular and covered with
tattoos and even eustus kid was
dumbfounded at the sight of him an earth
shattering debut for one of the most
Invincible creatures in one
piece
coming in in the top three of this list
we have escanor's debut with his massive
power the first time we saw escanor's
true power was a moment to behold and
widely regarded by fans of the series as
amongst the best when the Commandments
show up at escanor's bar Garland
inadvertently knocks out the skinny
escanor with a light tap on the shoulder
we already know that Garland is pretty
strong but even he could barely lift
escanor's axe escanor then appears in
all of his Splendor having been powered
up by the Sun so what does this insane
gentleman do next he literally Cuts
Garland in half everything they threw at
him just didn't do a single thing what
made this so awesome was the fact that
for us the Commandments were Unstoppable
but it took this one skinny dude to just
completely scare the life out of them it
was so freaking cool that you definitely
need to watch this moment or every
escanor moment for that matter
actually
at number two we have L's first
appearance from Death
[Music]
Note our protagonist Light Yagami has
been on a criminal killing spree and is
shown to be an exceptionally smart and a
very competent tactician that is until
the detective of the series L shows up
and puts him in his place in a strategic
Master Class El makes his debut as just
a voice having manipulated light into
giving away his country of origin and a
hint of his powers while announcing to
the world that he would capture the
killer Kira it was such an amazing
moment as before this point we thought
that light would be able to continue
bringing his form of Justice to the
world but he'd possibly met his better
in the form of L the debut completely
shifted the vibe of the series and was
the start of a cat and mouse chase that
would create millions of fans all around
the world not going to lie Death Note
was a hundred times better because of
him
[Music]
[Applause]
so at the top of this list we have mad
from
Naruto this villain changed the entire
scope of an allout War solely by himself
after his appearance he took on the
entire Shinobi Alliance single-handedly
decimating the ninjas after spending
spending some time with da Jutsu Madara
proceeds to summon an entire meteor it
took two carges to stop that meteor so
Madara just summoned another one on top
of it the situation becomes so bad that
all five gagay come to face Madara and
subsequently get their butts handed to
them the sheer power Madara demonstrated
was on a completely different level that
no one could fathom in Naruto's Universe
his power struck fear in everyone's
hearts and he casually defeated some of
the strongest Shinobi around all at the
time when he first truly appeared on
screen his debut wasn't only terrifying
to the Shinobi Alliance but to fans too
because no one could ever imagine how
they'd beat the man who was second only
to the god of
Shinobi and with that we wrap up this
list of the top 20 character debuts in
anime the number of character debuts is
numerous in this medium so I can imagine
we must have missed out some of your
favorites don't keep us hanging though
be sure comment down below any debuts
that you think should have made this
list if you enjoyed this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to see more of
this juicy content see you next time